hola qué tal después el presidente lópez
obrador en su mensaje de apertura hizo
un llamado a la integración del
continente americano un poco similar a
la que se dio con la comunidad económica
europea que dio paso a la actual unión
europea dijo lópez obrador que esto
sería posible únicamente si se parte de
tres premisas el respeto a la no
intervención la autodeterminación de los
pueblos y la cooperación para el
desarrollo dijo que es fundamental la
ayuda para evitar evitar la
discriminación y no someter a que un
ningún gobierno someta a otro con
condiciones o sanciones económicas ese
fue el mensaje inicial de lópez obrador
previo a esta ronda de participaciones
son 31 oradores los que participan en
esta sexta cumbre de la celac y también
lópez obrador hizo un llamado a que la
integración con eeuu y con canadá se dé
en el marco del peso de los pueblos se
hizo mucho hincapié en esto del ano
intervención en otros pueblos que
también es consecuente con el mensaje
que había dado la víspera en el marco de
la independencia de méxico cuando llamó
a estados unidos a levantar el bloqueo
contra cuba e hizo este exhorto
respetuoso a joe biden que por cierto
pues no tuvo respuesta del propio baile
pero sí del nuevo embajador que dijo que
respeta al gobierno de mexico pero que
seguirán con su plan respecto de la isla
maría contanos alguno de los hechos más
destacados al momento trascendió que
hubo algunos choques entre determinados
mandatarios verdad
es correcto todo comenzó cuando el
presidente de paraguay mario benítez
dejó en claro que su participación en
esta cumbre de ninguna manera
significaba un reconocimiento al
gobierno de nicolás maduro y maduro
desde su lugar lanzó el grito de que él
tampoco reconocía al gobierno de
paraguay
después vino la intervención de luis
lacalle gobierno del gobierno de uruguay
quien comenzó también diciendo que
estaba de acuerdo con la no intervención
que señalaba a lópez obrador